you mentioned Victor Frankel uh what
what do you make of his work man search
for meaning what are the the lessons you
draw from his work of him as a
psychologist but also from that a very
powerful work that reflects on his
experience in a in a in a Nazi
concentration camp yeah
I think that
it was
almost a profound
reinvention of humanness right after
something so
awful so Bleak and so despairing to
speak Anew about
shared humanness human connection yeah
meaning compassion
um that I think it was an intellectual
direction that that was adorned with all
of the emotions that we need to Adorn
the logic with in order to make real
change in the world and I think that his
work is has fueled you know so many
branches have come from you know from
his work existential Psychotherapy and
its place in in helping human activities
today right
um a a trend away from the idea that
that we're all quite isolated and that
what's going on between us is all very
transactional right I'm putting
something out and you take it in you put
something out I take it in right the
idea no there's a difference there's a
shared humanness that creates a meaning
beyond the transaction kind of like you
were just saying The Logical stuff isn't
really that interesting because you know
the logic is there's an answer to
whatever logic is we can do math half
right it's it's where does the the
surprises come in right either in terms
of of wonderful Behavior or destructive
Behavior right they're coming from
people's emotions so that's what we want
to understand and that occurs in the
context of a person and other humans you
know even if it's the conception of
someone and all and other humans as
enemy you know or it's the conception of
of two people uh sitting together the
idea that there's a shared humanist and
it's not all transactional and that he
could take that out of you know the the
a pinnacle of of human tragedy and
utilize it in a way that informs us
being better as a species going forward
I think is really monumental